[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a very
messed up Harry Potter theory of mine
that outlines some questionable actions
and behavior from Albus Dumbledore
suggesting that perhaps Dumbledore Wise
Old lovable benevolent Wizard and
Hogwarts Headmaster was actually a
master manipulator responsible for the
destruction of Lord Voldemort's Soul
this theory alleges that Dumbledore like
he did with Harry raised Voldemort like
a pig for Slaughter now let me start off
by saying that there are dozens of
theories out there which suggest that
when it comes to Dumbledore there's a
lot more than meets the eye one of the
predominant theories addresses
Dumbledore's relationship with Harry
Potter with fans arguing that Dumbledore
intentionally raised Harry to be a
sacrificial lamb knowing that Harry
would eventually have to die to destroy
the horcrux within him the theory
explains that Dumbledore manipulated
Harry's every move that he only revealed
crucial information to Harry when it was
absolutely necessary potentially guiding
Harry towards his predetermined fate
other theories painting Dumbledore's in
manipulative masterminds relate to his
relationship with Snape in the series
Dumbledore was able to convince name to
become a double agent by using Snape
slam for Lily Potter as leverage
Dumbledore was careful to keep Snape's
true Allegiance a secret from Harry and
the Order of the Phoenix which further
allowed him to manipulate events and
Snape behind the scenes but none at
least none that I've seen showcase
Dumbledore is quite capable of
manipulating the Future Dark Lord
Voldemort but who knows Voldemort better
than the man who pulled him out of false
orphanage and who better to manipulate
him than the very man that introduced
him to the World of Magic let's get into
it the first encounter between Albus
Dumbledore and Tom Riddle was in 1938
when Dumbledore visits was orphanage to
offer Tom a place at hog Court School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry during that a
meeting Dumbledore informs Tom about the
existence of The Wizarding World and his
magical Heritage and Tom who had already
sensed his own powers is intrigued by
the prospect of attending Hogwarts at
the time Tom was an 11 year old orphan
who had exhibited signs of magical
abilities but he was also known for his
manipulative and cruel Behavior towards
the other children at the orphanage on
the outside Tom looked fairly innocuous
but underneath was a brooding dark force
that would stop at nothing to cause pain
and suffering to others this encounter
between Dumbledore and Tom Riddle is
significant because it marks the
beginning of their complex relationship
throughout the series it also highlights
Dumbledore's role in the early life of
one of the most dangerous dark Wizards
in history raising questions about the
extent to which Dumbledore may have
influenced Tom's eventual transformation
into Lord Voldemort right from the very
beginning from their very first
encounter dumb law was cautious and wary
of the young boy sensing Tom's dark
nature potential for evil despite all of
the warning signs however Dumbledore
proceeds to offer Tom a place at
Hogwarts hoping that the school and new
environment would help shift Tom's life
in a more positive direction at least
that's what we're led to believe the
theory that we're going to be discussing
today asserts that Dumbledore upon
sensing this dark nature in Tom for the
very first time began his master plan to
manipulate this young boy
when Tom Riddle finally arrived at
Hogwarts he was sorted into Southern
house which was fitting as he was a
direct descendant of Salazar suthering
The house's founder as he Grew Older he
quickly became known for his charm and
intelligence excelling academically and
becoming a prefect in 1942 until his
graduation in 1945.
Tom didn't have friends per se but he
certainly did form relationships but
Dumbledore describing his gang as
follows as he moved up the school he
gathered about him a group of dedicated
friends I called him that for want of a
better term although as if already
indicated riddle undoubtedly felt no
affection for any of them this group had
a kind of dark glamor within the castle
they were a Motley collection a mixture
of the weak seeking protection the
ambitious seeking some shared glory and
the thuggish gravitating toward a leader
who could show the more refined forms of
Cruelty in other words they were the
forerunners of the Death Eaters and
indeed some of them became the first
Death Eaters after leaving Hogwarts over
the many years that Tom Riddle attended
Hogwarts few were able to detect riddles
underlying evil nature most were
distracted by the charm and intelligence
he exuded entirely unaware of what lay
beneath an exception to this however was
Dumbledore who kept a close iron riddle
from the very beginning Tom may not have
acted done his evil impulses like he did
at the orphanage but Dumbledore was more
perceptive than that unable to take his
eye off of the boy in whom he detected
so much darkness in 1942 just four years
after Dumbledore invited the troubled
young Tom Riddle to Hogwarts riddle
murdered Myrtle Warren in the first four
girls bathroom and created his first
horcrux Tom an avid student with an
obsession for achieving any kind of
power spent many of his nights in the
restricted section of the Hogwarts
Library learning about forms of dark
magic that were entirely inappropriate
for the average Hogwarts student it was
here that he began to learn about
horcruxes a form of dark magic which
transfers a piece of a witch or wizard
Soul into an object in order to achieve
immortality but the Restricted Section
didn't have all of the answers which
pushed young riddle in the direction of
Horus Slughorn head of Southern house
and one of Voldemort's confidence with a
little manipulation riddle ended up
getting just the answers that he needed
from Slughorn can completing his recipe
for horcruxes from this point onward
Voldemort's Soul began its downward
Journey from the day that he created his
first horcrux Voldemort began a cursed
existence where the only of a dark and
evil wizard but what Voldemort also
unknowingly did in the process was seal
his fate giving him a false sense of
security with regards to his alleged
immortality with all of the groundwork
Glade let me dive into what Dumbledore's
motivations may have been with regards
to this troubled young boy from the very
beginning Dumbledore knew that Voldemort
would one day be trouble as far as
judges of character go Dumbledore is one
of the best and who better to recognize
an up-and-coming dark wizard than a
former dark wizard Dumbledore invited
Tom Riddle to Hogwarts not to give him a
Wizarding education or set him on the
right path but instead to keep a
watchful eye over him ensuring that this
evil young boy wasn't off somewhere else
in the world doing whatever he pleased
and through observing Tom Riddle's
actions of the years his late night in
the Restricted Section manipulating
other students Etc Dumbledore only
became more and more sure of his initial
assessment as time went on which is why
just a few years after Tom Riddle had
begun attending the school Dumbledore
placed a book about horcrux's in the
Restricted Section and made it just
obvious enough for young Tom Riddle to
find Tom Riddle wasn't secretive about
wanting to become immortal and he had
discussed it with his gang on numerous
occasions what he didn't know however
was that he was under Dumbledore's
watchful eye how could Dumbledore
reasonably allow the heir of Southern to
walk around the Hogwarts Castle
unsupervised and because Dumbledore knew
about Tom Riddle's obsession with
becoming Immortal he decided that he
would leverage this piece of information
to his Advantage by planting the book on
Hall cruxes in the Hogwarts Library he
intentionally placed Voldemort on his
own path of Destruction knowing that a
damaged soul and a false sense of
security in his immortality through
horcruxes would only weakened Tom Riddle
in the long run we know that eventually
riddle seeks out horoslaghorn to fill in
the blanks on horcruxes what we never
find out however is how on Earth Horus
Slughorn knew about horcrux's himself in
the Wizarding World Knowledge of
supremely dark magic like that wasn't
exactly common which is why I think that
Dumbledore a former dark wizard himself
discussed it with Horus prior to
Riddle's conversation with him well
before planting the book riddle to find
and gently pushing him in that direction
Dumbledore had a candid conversation
with Cyclone about horcruxes where he
attempted to educate this head of
Southern house on the Mata by doing this
Dumbledore planted the seed of knowledge
in slachhorn's mind preparing him with
answers for the day that young Tom
Riddle came to him with questions from
the moment that young riddle completed
the puzzle that was horcrux creation he
set off on his dark journey to split his
soul and cement his immortality in 1942
he created the diary horcrux in 1943 he
created the ring horcrux in 1946 he
created the cup for krugs and sometime
between 1946 and 1979 he also created
both the locket horcrux and the diadem
horcrux in 1981 Voldemort inadvertently
created his sixth horcrux Harry Potter
and in 1994 Voldemort created his final
horcrux nagini each and every time
Voldemort created a new horcrux he
gained new confidence in the fact that
he was anchoring himself further and
further to the Mortal realm but from a
young age this boy wanted nothing more
than to be Tethered to life while he had
the power to end the lives of others but
what he never knew was that the friendly
old benevolent Dumbledore did visit him
in his orphanage had been pulling on the
strings the entire time Dumbledore knew
all along by setting Voldemort on the
path of horcruxes it would give him a
false sense of security rendering him
easier to defeat in the long run
Voldemort placed massive value in his
horcruxes but they came at the expense
of his soul each and every time he
created one he became less human and
relied on those objects more and more
for his own Survival Dumbledore knew
what Voldemort was capable of all along
but he wasn't going to just kill a child
in an orphanage instead he let
Voldemort's Life play out pulling at his
strings along the way and having
Voldemort create his own trump card for
the day that he pushed things too far in
this way Dumbledore was able to
manipulate the most feared dark wizard
to have ever lived on numerous occasions
Dumbledore had said himself that he
can't be trusted with power and who
better to assert his power over than a
troubled dark wizard with little
knowledge of the magical world in the
books and films were led to believe that
Dumbledore was totally in the dark on
horcruxes in fact the earliest point at
which we're led to believe Dumbledore
became aware of horcrux's was around the
time of Harry's parents deaths as he
told Snape that Voldemort would return I
think the Dumbledore knew about four
cruxes a lot earlier than that and I
think that he may have just played young
Tom Riddle in the same way that he may
or may not have played young Harry
raising him too like a pig for Slaughter
and that's it for this video I tried to
get really out there with this one and I
became really invested in the idea so
forgive me if something is out of whack
with regards to Canon what do you think
does any of this check out did I get any
of my facts wrong please leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live